you brought a picture that I really like  you found this sticker on your car and I  want to yeah Sarah this is you you found  this on your car can you did you blur  the battery you suck at parking your  vehicle always blocks the street you do  not own the street or sidewalk [ __ ]  here's a question right here's the thing  someone left that sticker on your car  that is beautifully made that is person  foot that's like a wedding invitation  i I I went crazy I mean how like  aggressive and rude is that isn't it  when I left and I know it was because I  was annoyed with the way she was  partying from the picture you can see  the tops of the letters of the next  label printed up multiple oh he's got a  cold you know he's got a sheet yeah yeah  so whenever it's someone does anything  here I try sticker on who's the [ __ ]  is my point or girl or girls  you